PROFESSOR: Today, we begin
with our study of scattering.
And so scattering
is the next chapter
in our study of approximations.
What is the purpose
of scattering?
Physicists want to study the
interactions between particles,
the forces.
We know, for example,
in a hydrogen atom
there is an electromagnetic
force within the proton
and the electron.
We understand it rather well.
But there are other
forces in nature
that we don't understand very
well, are harder to understand.
Those at higher energies, the
interactions between particles
can be rather complicated.
Also, it may happen that you
have a situation where there's
a potential affecting particles,
maybe a trap or something that
holds particles.
And there's a potential.
And you really cannot measure
directly this potential.
There's no simple
way of doing so.
And then what you do is
you send particles in.
And you see how
they get affected.
And by studying the
reflection or the scattering
of the particles off
of this potential,
you'll learn a lot about
what this potential can be.
So this subject
today is scattering.
And in general, you have a
beam of particles, a target,
and a number of detectors.
That's what happens
in a big accelerator.
And in general, you
have such situations.
OK?
So a beam, some sort of target,
and particles get scattered.
And you have detectors.
And in general, the detectors
are all over in all directions
because particles
may back scatter,
may go in different ways.
So collisions, in general,
are rather intricate.
Particles can change
identity, can do
all kinds of different things.
For example, you can have a
proton colliding with a proton.
This could be the case when
the beam is a beam of protons.
And here, maybe there's
a target in which
you study what happens when
a proton encounters a proton.
Or it may be that in
some cases there's
another beam that is
coming also with protons.
And they collide.
But when protons
collide with protons,
funny things can happen.
For example, you can
get the two protons
plus a pion, a neutral pion,
0 denoting zero charge.
That's a hadron, a strongly
interacting particle,
like the proton is.
It's made of quarks.
And this can happen.
There's no such thing
as a conservation
of the number of particles.
That is one of the reasons you
need quantum field theory to do
this kind of computation.
And this reaction is
allowed because it,
at least the first
thing you can check
is that it conserves charges.
Proton and proton go
to proton and proton,
so a charge is conserved.
And pi 0 is neutral.
So that, for
example, can happen.
Or proton plus proton can
go to proton plus neutron.
Now, charge is not conserved.
But this time, a positively
charged pion called pi plus.
The particles can
completely change identity.
You can have an electron
and a positron colliding.
So that's electron.
This is the positron, the
anti-particle of the electron,
equal mass, oppositely charged.
And then they can go into
a mu plus plus a mu minus.
These are charged laptons.
Again, just like the
electrical laptons, as opposed
to these particles here.
They're called hydrons.
These particles are, as far
as we know, are elementary.
These particles are
made out of quarks.
And in this case, you have a
complete change of identity.
The original particles
have disappeared.
And new particles
have been created.
And you can look forward
to study these processes
as you continue your studies
of quantum mechanics.
But these are like reactions.
Now, in our name, in our
nomenclature for scattering,
we will call the process
a scattering process
where the identity of the
particles is unchanged.
So we will have
scattering, strictly
speaking, when there is
no change of identity
in the initial and final states.
No change of identity of
the particles in the process
of going from initial
to final state.
So a scattering process looks
like a plus b goes to a plus b.
We don't change identity.
Those processes where you change
identity are harder to discuss.
And we won't discuss them here.
Even here, there is still a
lot of things that can happen.
It's very intricate.
So we will demand even more.
We will call or look
for elastic scattering.
And that means that if these
particles or objects have
internal states, those internal
states are not changed.
So the internal states of
the particles do not change.
Of course, that can
happen essentially
when the particles are complex.
They're bound states
of other particles.
So you may have a bound
state of one form.
And then when you
have bound states,
you know you have all kinds of
energy levels internal states.
And then when we say we
have an elastic process,
it means that those internal
states are not changed.
A classic example of
an inelastic scattering
experiment, the most
famous historically
of those experiments, is an
experiment by Frank and Hertz
in 1914.
They were having a
chamber with mercury gas.
And they shot electrons
from one side to the other.
And the electrons and the
mercury atoms collided.
And they found that the
electrons were slowed down
by some quantized
amount of energy.
And that was the first evidence
that atoms had energy levels.
Bohr's theory of atoms
had been proposed one year
before that, 1913.
And then, the process in which
these electrons hit the atoms
and lost energy corresponding
to producing transitions
in the atoms.
And that would be an
inelastic scattering
because the atom changed
its internal state.
This is a collision between
an electron and an atom,
but the atom has
changed internal states.
So we will want
to consider cases
when we don't change
the internal state.
And that will be when we
have elastic scattering.
So a few more things that
we're going to assume as we
do elastic scattering.
We will work without spin.
All we will do in the
next lectures, one or two
more lectures in this, will
be particles without spin.
As we're doing in
our course, we also
work in the nonrelativistic
approximation.
So these are the first
things that we will assume.
One, no spin.
This doesn't complicate
matters as far
as the scattering is concerned.
It just complicates the
algebra and the calculations
you have to do because you
have more degrees of freedom.
We will be working
nonrelativistically.
Moreover, we will assume
there are interactions.
There are interactions
between the particles
that produce the scattering.
And those interactions
are simple enough
that they just depend on
the difference of position.
So the interaction
potentials are
of the form v of R1 minus R2.
So processes in which will
have two incoming particles
and they interact, and
they scatter elastically.
And the potential depends
on just the difference
of the two positions.
Eventually, we will
even assume it's only
on the magnitude of
these differences
for particular cases.
But if you have a
potential like this,
like when we were
studying with hydrogen
atom for the first
time, a potential
that just depends on the
differences of positions
can be treated in the
center of mass frame.
It's a nice frame where
you can work on it.
And then you can think of
it as a single particle
scattering of a potential.
So you translate the
Schrodinger equation
into a center of mass
degrees of freedom
that are generally simple.
And we don't worry about and
a relative degree of freedom.
So this can be done here.
So this makes a process
equivalent to scattering
of a particle of a
potential V of r.
And that particle
has the reduced mass,
just like happened
with a hydrogen atom.
The real mass of the
equation we solve
for showing the Hamiltonian
for a hydrogen atom,
the mass that shows up
there is the reduced mass,
which is approximately
equal to the electron mass.
But in general, in this
scattering process,
it may be between two identical
particles in which case
a reduced mass would be half
the mass of the particle.
So again, we will
work scattering
with energy eigenstates.
You may have studied
already in 804
a little bit of problems
of scattering off
of rectangular barriers,
tunneling, all these things.
And we work with energy
eigenstates in those cases.
And we will work with energy
eigenstates as well here.
Now, in some versions of 804,
you discuss a lot wave packets.
I used to discuss
a lot wave packets.
We would build wave
packets and send them in.
And use a transmission on
reflection coefficients
to figure out what
the wave packets do.
And in general, a wave packet
is a somewhat more physical way
of thinking of the processes.
Because the energy states,
eigenstates, are unnormalizable
and don't have a
direct interpretation
in terms of particles.
Rigorously speaking,
you should always
do things with wave packets.
But the fact is that we all
work with energy eigenstates.
And most of the times, what
happens with wave packets
can be more or less gleaned
from what is happening
with energy eigenstates.
So we will not new
wave packets here.
We will not bother to
construct wave packets.
They would not teach us
too much at this moment.
So we will work with
energy eigenstates.